It is desired to use a crane to deposit an HVAC system onto a roof.
The crane is mounted on building B, as shown, and is intended to deposit its load onto
building A.
A tree stands in between buildings A and B, and its height prevents the crane from lowering
its boom arm below 50 degrees.
If the crane wishes to deposit the HVAC system, at least 20 feet away from the edge of the
building A roof, how long does the boom arm need to be in feet?
So this problem is all geometry.
We are looking for the length of the boom arm here, and given the other information we have
in blue, we can solve for that pretty quickly.
The problem also notes that the boom arm is restricted to being lowered to 50 degrees at most.
So if we were to draw this out really quickly, this could be our
conceptual step one.
We have X is what we're trying to solve for right now.
We have the distance.
We have the degrees that we've been given.
And we need to know that we need to cross a span of here to here, and also here to here.
So if we sum up 75 and 20 on the bottom, we don't even need the additional information about
the height of the building, and we don't need to compare the heights over here to the
height of this building.
We have enough information to solve this very quickly.
So rearranging the triangle, we can say that the cosine of the hypotenuse or the boom arm
is going to be equal to the adjacent over the hypotenuse.
So filling those in, we have a cosine of 50 degrees equals 95 over the hypotenuse.
Solving for that, the hypotenuse is going to be equal to 95 divided by the cosine of 50.
And this is going to be 147.5 feet.
This would make our closest answer over here 150.